let's play we good we good
hey that's what I'm talking about they
go come out and try to throw a punch we
got to keep swinging too we gonna be all
right just keep playing with Force keep
being physical
you come outside the screen set it set
to set the foundation before we get to
the slips and all the flakes and all of
that we got to establish physicality we
ain't going nowhere so I'm talking about
we ain't going nowhere
we're going nowhere
Diamond Ham's gonna be 50 this summer
his first year as head coach in L.A for
the Lakers a lot of times an assistant
coached in the D-League back when it was
the D-League he's had a life in
basketball played eight years in the NBA
was on the Pistons 2004 NBA championship
team played for a bunch of teams also
played in Spain the Philippines Puerto
Rico has been all over the world and he
just loves the game and has done a
terrific job with this team former
teammate of mine great guy who once
broke a backboard and glad he's got the
opportunity he's done an outstanding job
with his dunking or a shooting
[Applause]
that was back in the NCAA tournament
when a Texas Tech in the sweet 16 when
he did that I'll tell you hachimura has
really been
an efficient jump shooter in this
playoff so far
offensive foul called
against Golden State on Curry
[Music]
and there it is
he could jump out the building against
North Carolina that's right on search
Wicker's head
and Vince Carter's in the picture Anton
Jamison
don't call me out if I'm just in the
picture
and that was Tim Higgins the official
underneath you know the officials